[Music]
I'd say what no they were they were
downright they wanna other can better
design I have no idea
[Music]
[Music]
were back [ __ ] you thought it's
Monday night weapon eight minutes
[ __ ] left what's the final it was
four minutes what was the final score
was the score right now what's the score
right now oh [ __ ] we both scored again
what's up you bad [ __ ] first
things first happy New Year to you and
your families may this year be the most
prosperous and healthy is [ __ ] year
your family has ever had you understand
me
because without your help you got
nothing if you can't get a hard-on you
can't get your dicks up does that easy
understand me so get it together work on
that [ __ ] hard-on for 2017 besides
that the boys are here we're just doing
a few bonnets shine on you crazy diamond
we got a big bag of stars tonight and
we're gonna mix them tonight with la
Luna aka the [ __ ] moon look these
[ __ ] savages up and these savage you
want to mix them both together like an
atomic bomb and your [ __ ] head you
understand me let's start this party off
on the right foot it's [ __ ] 2017 row
opening up with 1200 right off the bat
too
for a double a meteor that's how we do
it 1200 right off the bat I'm giving Li
one with a tail you get a wing you got
sixty and joy [ __ ]
always remember when you want to see the
devil you gotta go with Star Wars they
are a direct line to the [ __ ] devil
these piece right here you got stuff on
your mind there's things you want to
change it starts with the star one aka
stars of debt that's right [ __ ]
let's do another bung that I haven't
seen in a while it's good to see you
guys I missed you and a nice time yes
there on the road and experience with
those [ __ ] lunatics and now today
we're gonna bring the craziness back to
the church where it belongs you [ __ ]
what's ugly you said you weren't
training you're making funny faces and
[ __ ] you gotta make funny faces when you
eat the stars we're gonna see these
chocolates now see what they got for us
we got a couple different types of
reefer you have this Armenian wheat
that's [ __ ] tremendous this is the
last [ __ ] Ronda Rousey smoked before she
got punched in the head by the Brazilian
dad
[Music]
that goes on a little bit there anyway
it's over people
this [ __ ] we don't kill you this [ __ ]
and this is what my main man grew we got
weed coming from all over the understand
me the only thing we need here is you
[ __ ]
[Music]
well you've been in training so you'll
be fine and Heil that [ __ ] thing he's
got a good way you know one of the best
bars Evan
when they come with a wing you're going
deep tonight you can't even see through
the wing you see that we got the [ __ ]
he hit the Jacobin is the crackerjack
bucks he got the good stuff I hope you
guys are well I hope you starting a year
off on the right foot I hope you got
your head together I hope you have a
plan again
Nietzsche a man without a plan is not a
man so get your [ __ ] together
90 day 60 day 120 day 360 day whatever
the [ __ ] you need a two day plan
whatever the [ __ ] you need start that
[ __ ] right now you start right
now right through this bucket your first
[ __ ] thing I gotta do more buckets
that's it
[Music]
I think that was on your on your list
what's that I was always on my list you
understand me you always got to raise
the level of bong hits if not you know
[ __ ] sink into the [ __ ] the
sinkhole of life I'm over here offering
you an escape without join in
Scientology or any of these other
[ __ ] organizations where you gotta
walk around and you can't be yourself
you understand me why join an
organization so what's he have some
stupid [ __ ] friends listen I better
be happy and be alone than misery and
have a bunch of [ __ ] idiots around me
trust me it's been working for me for
years
try try
I'm trying things the bed you gotta
[ __ ] put it together somewhere I
didn't do much last week I just worked
out I went to jujitsu I hit okay I only
have one piece of pumpkin pie I didn't
find around last week oh my protein
shakes I told you that over the holidays
is way you could fall apart man and I
fell apart a couple of nights one night
I got so hot by myself I had a bag of
cookies nobody thought I believed when I
get cut I got high what are you doing I
ate three I was eating two really shot
the next thing you know the cookie bag
was [ __ ] gun out I got up the next
day and walk around two blocks and
diabetic test is [ __ ] but that was the
only night I slipped on all the holidays
I got really high one night and my wife
made a mistake him what these [ __ ]
cookies at me but besides that I worked
out I I watched that I avoided the milk
or you could do is try Pro this little
[ __ ] things you could do is dry I'm
never gonna be my Dolce I know that go
on it I smoked too much weed I like my
[ __ ] food you know I like my apples
can find the time I like a Sabourin hot
dog but I've been avoiding sweets I've
been really good with [ __ ] sweets cos
I don't want to [ __ ] throw in a
diabetic bill you know I'm saying yeah
so if anything I owe you a bigger piece
of steak something you know well yeah
one night last week I went deep by
myself like the dirtiest one of those
nights like tonight before Christmas
there was cookies [ __ ] Milano's oh
[ __ ] my wife never memories [ __ ] you
know you didn't like school but you know
you're nobody's fool so welcome to the
machine
[Music]
you like that huh [ __ ] I hope
you're doing bong get saucy and I leave
me like some [ __ ] drug at it and if
you're under 18 get off this
[ __ ] right now [ __ ] up this
I'll call your mother right yeah it's
time for some chocolate now we're going
right for the jugular right for the DNA
you slice this like a [ __ ] animal
understand me you rip the bag up and you
let it no you wait [ __ ] it it's got a
zip leg you can eat a piece and put it
back go [ __ ] yourself all right
I don't need no piece and put it back we
go deep into the murky waters of the
underworld again la luna AKA moon that's
what your [ __ ] gone [ __ ]
[Music]
yummy for your tummy
[Music]
delicious
I wish you were here with me what's up
Li you having a heart attack over there
it's gonna work out just fine people
2017 was the year you've been waiting
for trust Leung chun-ying you [ __ ]
around enough I know what that was like
for years I kept kicking myself when he
has New Year's Day lying to me but if I
stop the coke nothing got put together
don't get me wrong I made some strides
but that heavy drug usage [ __ ] killed
me thank God we're here we're here to
spend some time together
face the faces shall we what's going on
[Music]
would right [ __ ] get January 2nd
you gotta stop the year off right
there's new year amateurs they're
amateurs it's the next day where you see
the [ __ ] devil
we make a noise Wow
sensational but it's it's [ __ ]
tremendous guys I love doing this
podcast hanging out with you
[ __ ] especially this pre pre
podcast where we get to [ __ ] exchange
thoughts nothing like this listen well I
stopped doing coke my site when I can't
see when I was doing coke I had 20/20
but I can't see that [ __ ] so you can
write whatever the [ __ ] you want unless
I got my glasses and I ain't going down
you understand me
poor leaves over here choking the depth
look at him he's turning purple
[Music]
[Laughter]
you see what happens he told me it was
in training last week
oh no [ __ ] you puked it look at this I
gotta eat a beaut
he told me was in training and went to
Long Beach I am what am i got do it you
look at you you puked up a guest see
what happens you see what happens when
you don't try it on with who taught you
didn't eat that job you you would
[ __ ] faint on periscope you see what
happened here take some more tissues
[Music]
he go he go
all week what are you doing I'm on
vacation you see what happens they don't
train they don't keep it up and down
it's fun
the chocolate was coming out of his
[ __ ] mouth you gotta love it you know
I'm saying that's what happens when you
run with uncle Joey I'll prepare many
have tried diesel but what are we gonna
do about it and see what's
crack-a-lackin' poor kid [ __ ] coming
out like a geyser you see I'm talking
I got tougher these kids up I'm trying
with all my heart every day for cookies
and 80s I didn't see nothin I don't see
not all I know is guys is coming out cuz
he doesn't train enough
he thinks I'm [ __ ] around here at the
church you gotta be tip-top Magoo to
walk in those [ __ ] doors you
understand me if not that's what happens
we're not [ __ ] around here no
whatever no [ __ ] charity here what a
real deal I've been telling you that
[ __ ] for years all these other
California
you said I got to deal with you guys
think I got an easy [ __ ] life here
between him and my wife they gotta put
me in a [ __ ] grave broken up together
[Music]
tip-top Magoo if you gonna be a member
to church you gotta train beep every
week bong hits out of bulls meshuggener
pills whatever you got
well [ __ ] leave look
they would you do too chocolatey picked
up your like that back Jesus Christ and
that means you pick the stars you can
eat those six stars again Jesus Christ
you said I got through guys do you
understand I'm trying to say to you
[ __ ] I try hard I'll lead them
to water but they don't want to drink it
they think my Uncle Joe they think I got
here well as Moses I'm no [ __ ] genius
I'm no genius I got left back in the
seventh grade guys you know how dumb you
gotta be to get left back in the seventh
grade I didn't graduate high school high
school diploma I tell him we you gotta
train I don't give a [ __ ] away you go
you gotta eat two thousand a day smoked
reefer cuz once you get into these rooms
here in the church there's no coming
back
come in here big boy have a cigar you're
gonna go far oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
yo he'll be right out posit oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] going down time
you all right now yeah you sure let me
look at you that's right look at him he
never knows what shirt is that gonna fit
you duck oh my god [ __ ] hilarious
rule number one of the church another
train he stated trendy a the style his
girlfriend and they watch splashes [ __ ]
[Music]
it was coming out his [ __ ] fingers he
shooting up into the sky he had
chocolate fudge ah [ __ ] tremendous he
Sam Sam you can't write this [ __ ] is the
better dog what having a great time
doing this shoot we're having a great
[ __ ] time cuz this is as good as it
gets
there's no directors there's no
executive producers as [ __ ] goes down
like this there's no this ain't reality
TV this is mother [ __ ] mad flames
world [ __ ] get it in your [ __ ]
skull these mother [ __ ] you've been
running with for years then lift this
laisse blah life and everything's done
for everybody else I do what the [ __ ] I
wanna my [ __ ] rules you understand me
that's why I have these [ __ ]
don't run with flavor what get your [ __ ]
together the old fathers of the [ __ ]
house now
myself Happy New Year my brother let me
finish this bun all right happy to you
look at the wall on [ __ ] periscoping
we got the Alpha will you head it from
here
you got those spots tonight oh [ __ ] bo
Vaughn's here listen and then you got
the hitter hassling you draw pop that
[ __ ] it's worth the wait listen if
you don't gonna get in trouble
trust me the first puke of the [ __ ]
year already you know why you can't rain
[ __ ] the train you saw me then train
that's what happens
I [ __ ] Lee whistles buzz right baby
boy you bad [ __ ] what start the
year off with a bag with a [ __ ]
Bewkes Benjamin just ran out of love you
[ __ ] I see you in ten minutes
happy New Year to you and your families
what is it you to.com
Sassy's class shirt so that's Joey Diaz
mark I don't know what the [ __ ] to tell
you you know I'm saying all I can tell
you is it's the old Vaughn and full
effect Lee already puked and I'm seeing
the devil so we're off to a good [ __ ]
stunt
I'll see you [ __ ] in ten
minutes they blacker than black
what's happening